A CDL driver operates large vehicles like tractor trailers,...
...flatbed trucks, tow trucks and buses for commercial use.
CDL is short for commercial driver's license.
So, is the commercial trucking industry right for you?
First, let's check out your odds.
There are 32,215 available jobs listed on CareerBuilder right now.
Here are some other words you should use to search for a CDL driver job:...
...truck driver, driver and delivery driver.
And here are the three cities where you're most likely to find companies...
...hiring for CDL driver jobs right now.
It's also helpful to know what skills and education...
...employers want a typical CDL driver to have.
If you've completed high school, you're likely in good shape.
70.5 percent of CDL drivers have a high school level education.
When it comes to years of experience on the job,...
...here's how the CDL driver position breaks down on a national level.
The top three skills employers want CDL drivers to have are:...
...commercial driver's license, DOT medical card and tractor trailer experience.
If this sounds like a position for you, good news!
You're in demand!